Valentine's Day is coming up and you
have a you guys have made a special
Valentine's Day show yes and your do you
have memories of your any awkward
Valentine's Days mean that Isaak sucks
right like I mean it's kind of the worst
like because either you're not in a
relationship and you feel like you
should be or you are in a relationship
and there's this pressure about what are
you gonna do right and and and I had one
great Valentine's Day and it was
actually it was I lost my virginity on
Valentine's you did yeah it was actually
a year ago thank you that's a lot of
pressure if you planned it like yeah I
don't lose my virginity today when I'm
39 it's gonna be gonzo I'm a geek card
and by the way watch gonzo on the v card
PBS I love it when you use slang thank
you
that's it's so but I did lose my
virginity it was like Presidents Day
weekend I was in college I was like 19
and I lost my virginity to a girl who I
had gotten to know him was friends with
and then we sort of realized as we were
hooking up were like we're both virgins
you wanna so we it was really very kind
of sweet and it happened in my sister's
bed oh my god
yeah is that true yeah it is true what
what's wrong with you well what's wrong
with the earth yeah isn't you don't you
have a bedroom in the same house that
your sister has a bedroom who says like
listen let's not jump the kink Factory
my sister's room yeah yeah and then we
took a shower in my parents shop
ah wow they were sleeping in the
bathroom yeah no nobody was home I had
to stay in my sister's room yeah yeah
you know to get hard so you can know
this goes out cutting that that's
staying in make sure that stays there
yeah I'm sure that that's gonna make
everything interesting Nick you've had a
great career I'd like to apologize it
was a different time yeah almost one
minute ago yeah one minute ago when you
said that it was a different time man
you guys don't learn so much about
myself in the last minute